jean-pierre on apprend en tunisie'' ya
des personnes qui nous ont contactés
pour adresser un message oui alors est
ce que tu es en conflit avec des gens en
ce moment a priori nouveau est ce qu'il
ya des gens que tu n'as pas revu depuis
longtemps et ont cherché à avoir de tes
nouvelles récemment je ne sais pas
comment c'est ce que tu as une ex qui
auraient des raisons de vouloir un
contact et aaa
non je sais pas si c'est ce que tu
penses que c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise surprise
je ne sais pas mais moi je te propose de
regarder les images pour essayer de
deviner qui a décidé de te dire quelque
chose de très important ce soir
regarde cher jean pierre
tu as passé toute sa vie à défendre nos
régions notre gastronomie ainsi que le
savoir faire français
et rien pour ça nous sommes tous
reconnaissants et les français doivent
beaucoup
en ce qui nous concerne cela fait 17 ans
que nous nous côtoyons quotidiennement
17 ans que tu es dans la vie comme à
l'écran une personne formidable
généreuse aimante
on te l'a peut-être pas assez dit
message que le plus beau cadeau que la
vie nous est fait c'est de t'avoir comme
père on t'aime papa
[Musique]
là
oui
selon lui
ça va mais si je peux pas vous
pourtant les deux ans
[Applaudissements]
au pire tu étais pas du tout au courant
c'est la maison attention de bien
méchant
vous êtes une famille magnifique jeu les
routes
franchement vous adore
c'est dire c'était peut-être une star du
jt mais je vous le dis ces deux stars de
tik tok louer top 10 cet été s'il
n'arrêtait pas bien desservi mais nous
ne t'oublions de gênes sur ton tik tok
waouh non mais sans rire et n'hésite pas
à parler de ton père même le mettre en
scène
regarder une petite compil nez merci
d'être là regardez franchement c'est à
six voies la cci c'est magnifique ce
qu'on vit de ce soir merci la ville de
son père de paris née ma vie est
incroyable il pourrait remplacer dans
dix ans tout de suite moi je suis là
[Musique]
véronique fait un infarctus tu as dit
quoi je ne te reconnais pas sur les
photos
ces pages 36 tu du coup j'ai dit je te
disais que je fais pas la gueule j'ai
pas dit que tu étais moi je ne te
reconnais pas sur les photos
[Musique]
je saurai mois
non
attention à leur taille car ne nous
étonne je situerais
vous êtes un mythe vous êtes content que
papa j'ai l'impression que le
confinement
ça vous a fait prendre conscience aussi
que vous aviez envie de rester plus
ensemble tous les quatre c'est ça je la
10e bloqués pendant deux mois il avait
bien envie deux basses qui est bien du
coup c'est qu'il va pouvoir venir faire
des petits footings avec moi le dit moi
je pense pas très bien et m'emmener au
karting le samedi matin et loup bah moi
je suis contente qu'il fasse enfin ceux
qui se reposent un petit peu et tant
qu'il est content moi je suis pas jean
pierre mallet quand on attendait pas
moins